the senate has moved to increase funding
for the security of supreme court
justices amid growing concerns about
their safety abortion rights
demonstrations continue nationwide in
the d.c area protesters gather outside
some of the justices homes to make their
voices heard before congress debates the
issue tomorrow scott mcfarland scott
mcfarland is outside the high court this
morning scott what more can you tell us
hey naked morning crews have erected
these tall black metal fences around the
entirety of this complex it's an added
layer of security in an area that's
accustomed to protests but it's now the
homes of supreme court justices where
protesters have gathered last night it
was outside the home of justice samuel
alito the author of that draft leaked
supreme court opinion on abortion rights
the protesters have found the homes of
other justices the chief justice
included
in a statement the white house press
secretary says
protests should never include violence
threats or vandalism and that judges
should be free to do their jobs without
concern for their personal safety the
u.s marshals say they've increased
security help to the high court and last
night the u.s senate passed a bill
extending additional security not just
to the justices but to their families
meanwhile an intelligence bulletin
reviewed by cbs news warns extremists
could be mobilizing during this powerful
debate nationwide potentially targeting
abortion clinics and government
officials as for this black fencing this
is very reminiscent to what we saw
across the street outside the capitol
after the january 6th attack no one
likes the looks of it but the belief is
gail it could deter
attacks
you're right scott unfortunately it
looks very familiar thank you very much